hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American sci-fi television
show called For All Mankind spoilers ad
watch out and take care
[Music]
the show is set in a parallel universe
and it begins in the year 1969 everyone
around the world is taken aback by the
first moon landing however it's actually
the Soviets who have accomplished this
the people at Nasa are in Shock as they
watch a Soviet Cosmonaut become the
first person to step foot on the moon
come comrade free cheese for everyone
the next day at a meeting the chief of
the astronaut office Deke Slayton
reveals that Apollo 11 America's latest
attempt to send a man to the Moon is
scheduled to launch in two weeks so he
orders astronauts Neil Armstrong Buzz
Aldrin and Michael Collins to continue
with their training as planned however
the news of the Soviets sending the
first man to the moon has shaken the
morale of the astronauts they appear
distraught so Deke decides to let them
take the weekend off the astronauts
appreciate this and go to a bar which is
famous among NASA employees there a
reporter approaches astronauts Ed
Baldwin and his crewmate Gordo Stevens
it turns out the two were crew members
of the Apollo 10 Mission Hussain was to
travel close to the moon's surface and
observe the landing conditions for
Apollo 11. they are now set to go on the
Apollo 15 Mission the reporter pester
zeden Gordo about losing to the Soviets
and makes snide remarks about them
returning back to Earth without landing
on the moon this upsets a drunk Ed and
he goes on a rant against NASA he
reveals that the space organization is
scared of taking risks after the first
Apollo Mission tanked and resulted in an
accident that killed all the crew
members the scene then cuts to the NASA
HQ where the main administrator Thomas
Payne astronaut office Chief Deke and
director of manned spacecraft Center
Werner Von Braun demand answers from a
CIA agent as the American spy agency
failed to warn NASA about the Soviet
moon landing in the cia's defense the
agent replies that they reported two
unmanned rocket launches but they turned
out to be manned desperate to get an
American on the moon as soon as possible
Thomas asks if they could move up the
launch of the Apollo 11 but Von Braun
rejects the idea the next day Ed's
earlier comment about NASA go viral
viral it's in the news this obviously
doesn't sit well with the superiors so
Deke reprimands him and reveals that Von
Braun has decided to remove him from the
Apollo 15 Mission instead Ed will be
assigned to a normal office job the
latter tries to protest the decision but
Deke won't hear any of it following this
the story skips forward one month and
Apollo 11 is finally ready for launch at
Mission Control flight director Jean
Krantz gives a motivational speech to
all the staff and reminds them that the
outcome of the mission will shape
America's future for space travel
moments later Apollo 11 finally launches
and the entire nation watches tensely
from their homes to everyone's Delight
the craft safely reaches space and
ultimately the moon's orbit afterwards
Neil and Buzz make their way towards the
moon's surface while Michael stays
behind in lunar orbit as Ed watches the
mission from the bar his wife Karen
attends a watch party hosted by deke's
wife Marge the two get to talking and
Marge explains that Deke could put Ed
back in the Apollo 15 Mission if he
publicly states that he was misquoted by
the reporter however Karen mentions the
duty honor and the truth matter a lot to
her husband and he would never agree to
it elsewhere Neil and Buzz slowly
approached the moon's surface and
prepare for landing however as they get
closer they struggle to find a good spot
this makes the two Panic so they are
forced to make an Abrupt Landing because
of this the mission control loses
telemetric connection and all other
means of communication with Apollo 11.
mission control that's one small step
for man several hours passed by and
after not hearing from Apollo 11 Von
Braun concludes that the spacecraft is
likely to have crashed they even asked
Michael who is in Orbit to return back
to Earth but just then the mission
control receives a transmission from
Neil who lets them know that Apollo 11
has successfully landed on the moon this
sends all of the NASA staff into a state
of ecstasy they start to celebrate while
Neil hoists the stars and stripes and
becomes the first American on the moon
after a while Neil and Buzz wrap up
their mission on the Moon and reunite
with Michael in orbit then the three of
them set course for Earth and they
didn't even need Stanley Kubrick's help
two months passed by and Ed has become
fed up with his desk job one day he
confronts Deke and asks him to reinstate
him as a member of the Apollo 15 crew
however the boss is still unwilling to
take him back later NASA administrator
Thomas Payne conducts a meeting with the
other high-ranking officials saying that
he has some bad news he suspects that
the Soviets are planning to set up a
lunar base on the moon having already
lost one race to them Thomas is adamant
on avoiding another humiliation so he
orders Von Braun to quickly take
initiative and build the first military
outpost on the moon before the Soviets
do Thomas also mentions that the order
has come directly from president Richard
Nixon himself I am not a crook I was
twice meanwhile it's revealed that Von
Braun used to work in Germany where he
developed the V2 Rockets these Rockets
were used by the Germans in World War II
and they claimed the lives of hundreds
and thousands of innocent people the
therefore Von Braun rejects the
president's orders stating that he
doesn't want to turn space travel into
another Battlefield later he talks to
his disciple Margot Madison who is an
engineer at Nasa she appears to have an
interview with the flight director Jean
for a position in Mission Control
unfortunately the interview does not go
as planned and Margot leaves the office
in frustration she is certain that she
will not get selected however the next
day Von Braun enters her office and
proudly announces that she is the first
woman to ever be in Mission Control
hearing this Margot becomes excited and
hugs him tightly in the next scene Ed is
approached by administrator Thomas Payne
and a congressman the latter gives Ed a
chance to get back into the Apollo 15
program but only if he does them a favor
Ed will have to bring Von Braun down by
falsely testifying in front of the
committee who are investigating NASA's
failures that is hesitant about the
offer as although he doesn't see eye to
eye with Von Braun he still respects him
the congressman simply asks him to think
about it revealing that even the
president wants it to happen a few
Slater and is seen at the Congress
Hearing in Washington D.C surprisingly
instead of framing Von Braun he takes
the fall for the Apollo 10 Mission much
to the congressman's dismay later he
resigns from NASA and decides to
re-enlist in the Navy nevertheless the
hearing committee manages to Corner Von
Braun by bringing up his work
association with Nazi Germany Von Braun
expresses extreme regret over the misuse
of his work by the Third Reich and
claims that it has no relevance to his
work at Nasa in response the congressman
reveals various photos and hard proof
that Von Braun had also been a part of
the SS the Nazi secret police which was
known for its brutality against Jews
this proves to be the final nail in the
coffin for Von Braun and he is
ultimately relieved of his duties at
Nasa I am innocent peace I love the Jews
the scene then cuts to the launch of the
Apollo 12 mission which is set to
explore the moon and find a suitable
sight for the lunar base the same day
Deke pays Ed with some good news after
the termination of Von Braun the new
director has decided to reinstate him
back into the Apollo 15 Mission the news
elates Ed as it has always been his
dream to do something for his country as
the two continue talking Karen arrives
there and asks them to turn on the news
surprisingly the news reports that the
Soviets have sent another spacecraft on
the moon and this time a female Russian
cosmonaut has successfully stepped foot
on the moon making her the first woman
ever to achieve such a feat the
Americans are livid at the achievement
and with pressure mounting on them they
make it their ultimate goal to set up a
lunar base before the Soviets therefore
Gene and Deek decide to also assign
Apollo missions 13-15 to survey
potential sites for a lunar base shortly
after NASA administrator Thomas Payne
enters the room and informs the two that
the president now wants a woman on the
moon this is a problem for NASA as it
doesn't have any female astronauts
however Thomas suggests the names of two
potential candidates Molly Cobb and
Patty Doyle both of them were part of
the now defunct Mercury 13 project whose
aim was to send women to space before it
got canceled in the early 60s Deke takes
both women into consideration and he is
presented with more potential candidates
including Danielle Poole a NASA engineer
later Thomas tells Deke that the
president has floated an idea to send
Gordo Stevens to space with his wife
Tracy who is also a former pilot Deke is
hesitant about the idea but Thomas
forces him to get on board later Deke
visits Gordo's residence and briefs the
couple about the proposal to his
surprise they love the idea and accept
it without hesitation upon seeing Gordo
unusually excited Tracy gets suspicious
and it's then revealed that Dee could
offered him a guaranteed slot on the
Apollo 15 Mission if he managed to
convince his wife to undergo Astronaut
training following this we are taken to
the year 1970 Tracy and 19 other female
candidates enter their Astronaut
training class Deke introduces himself
and remind the ladies that it will be a
very rigorous training all of them will
be graded and the ones with the best
results will proceed to the next stage
of the program the course starts and
Tracy in particular has difficulties
keeping up with the other candidates she
continuously ranks last as the number of
candidates drops to 10. Tracy also
starts considering dropping out from the
program and this results in a heated
argument between Gordo and her he tries
to convince her that it is a golden
opportunity but Tracy believes that he
is only doing this for himself in the
next scene we are taken to a NASA
meeting where they are discussing some
pictures of the Moon taken by a
satellite the pictures reveal the
possibility of the presence of ice
there's also a little man in there Gene
mentions that water on the moon could
change everything similarly an engineer
emphasizes that they may be able to
drink the water grow plants and even
make rocket fuel maybe even get
superpowers like in their Marvel Comics
however this cannot be confirmed and Ed
mentions that they will find out more
about it on the Apollo 15 mission after
the meeting Thomas asks Deke about the
female astronaut training program RAM
and the latter reveals that he has set
up desert training for the women this is
because he wants to prepare them for a
potential scenario if they botched their
Landing from space into unknown
territory at the desert survival
training Deke briefs the women about
their next test they will have to reach
a certain destination in the desert and
everyone will be graded and timed on
their individual performances soon the
test begins and all the women begin
their Journey under the scorching hot
sun after hours of walking Tracy notices
that a fellow candidate named Ellen has
injured her ankle without any hesitation
she tends to her wounds and slowly makes
her way to the Finish Line with Ellen
sacrificing her own mission that was a
Chad move a Harry Potter ass move you
know meanwhile Mercury 13 alumni Molly
and Patty reach the Finish Line before
anyone else Tracy and Allen are the last
ones to make it much to the astonishment
of Deke who is surprised by Tracy's
generosity the next day the names of the
remaining five candidates are announced
and to everyone's surprise Tracy and
Alan have made it on the list along with
Patty Danielle oh and Molly shortly
after Deke caused Tracy into his office
and compliments her on her Instinct and
guts but he also mentions that guts
alone isn't enough she needs to be
competent and selfish saying this deep
gives Tracy an option to voluntarily
withdraw her name from the program
however she refuses stating that she is
in all the way and wants to be an
astronaut badly on the 200th day of the
training program Ed takes the five
remaining candidates to a military base
and introduces them to a lunar
exploration module AKA Lem simulator
which can emulate the flight dynamics of
the Apollo spacecraft here the
candidates will be performing basic
takeoff and Landing Maneuvers Tracy is
the first to enter the lamb half an hour
later as Gordo Drives By the military
base he notices an ominous cloud of
black smoke emerging from inside the
base worried Gordo rushes to the base
where he discovers that Paddy crashed
the module because of which she has
passed away the incident devastates the
remaining four women so much that they
start considering to leave the program
altogether one day a former astronaut
named John Glenn visits Deke at his
office in NASA HQ it turns out he was
the first American to enter space John
advises Deke to cancel the women's
astronaut project as he opines that it
is best for the future of NASA I'm
old-fashioned you see and I don't like
women Deke however refuses to do so as
he has trained the female astronauts
continuously for almost a year later at
a NASA meeting Gene reveals that
satellite images show that a Soviet
spacecraft has crashed on the moon which
is claimed the life of at least one
Cosmonaut although the Soviets have kept
the mission and the incident under rafts
the CIA suspects that they were trying
to set up a lunar base near the alleged
ice formations this makes NASA realize
that the Soviets are again one step
ahead after the meeting Thomas
approaches Deke inside his office and
informs him that the women's training
program has been canceled by the higher
authorities much to his dismay the scene
then cuts to a surprise press conference
at the NASA HQ there Deke speaks to the
media and announces that Danielle Allen
Molly and Tracy are the first women to
successfully pass NASA's required
Astronaut training and introduces them
as astronauts this makes the reporters
very confused and happy at the same time
later dick visits added informs him that
he has decided to replace Gordo with
Molly as the crew of the Apollo 15
Mission and is not pleased with the
removal of his friend but Deke forces
him to have dinner with his new
crewmates Molly and Frank Sedgwick the
third Apollo Cosmonaut expectedly Gordo
is devastated by the news and he returns
home drunk this initially infuriates
Tracy but when she learns about his
dismissal from the Apollo 15 Mission she
immediately Comforts him meanwhile
during her training for the Apollo 15
Mission Molly gets into an argument with
her new crewmates Ed and siegweek
because of her stubbornness when Margot
learns about it she reprimands Molly and
reminds her that she is an astronaut so
she has to be perfect in every aspect
this involves being social and
Cooperative fortunately Molly takes the
feedback well and she corrects her ways
the scene then skips to the day of the
Apollo 15 launch where the three crew
members Ed Sedgwick and Molly are
strapped into the rocket as soon as it
takes off Dee gets a call from the
president who congratulates him on the
launch however he also warns Deke that
if Molly screws up he will face the
consequences check out part two on
mystery recapped I am not a crook